I do think people would love to see a
dr. Quinn Medicine Woman reboot hang out
we're trying right now
Beth Sullivan's come up with most
amazing concept of what it would be
would be 26 years later Joe's on board
Williams on board we all want to do it
we are actively right now trying to get
the rights to do it I think it belongs
on Netflix don't you I do have you
talked to Netflix about oh I haven't but
we're in the process of trying to find a
way to get it on the straining place
because I think that's where it belongs
yeah and do you miss that character I
can watch her every day she's playing
somewhere all over the world yeah yeah
actually I don't miss her at all because
my closets full of her and I see Joe
Lando all the time yes and a lot of the
people that I worked with on that show
is still my closest friends but she's a
great character
she's so appropriate for now yes I mean
you know if you were ever going to have
a character that belongs in this
generation with what's going on in the
world we need her you'd star in it of
course absolutely or we'd have young
people there okay any pretty green yes
yes Jane Seymour is ready to bring back
dr. Quinn and hopefully wedding crashers
this is clear I don't come again okay
can't call me okay there's been a lot of
talk about a wedding crashers too oh I'd
love that too
what's the status I don't nothing I no
no no nothing nothing we got to make
that happen
I hopefully can be good as wedding
crashers one because wedding crashers
one was my favorite comedy of all time
it was incredible I read that and this
is a classic thing of people who do
smaller roles in big films that was a
small role I read that role and I said
this is the role this is the funniest
thing I've ever read in my life and I
know exactly what I want to do it I had
to screen test for it did you really
Weiss I had to fight fight for this
thing and the funniest thing is that the
director and producer the younger ones
yeah had never seen me in anything other
than James Bond so what had I been doing
for you know 40 years you've had one of
the men sitting around since James Bond
doing nothing I know it was hilarious
hilarious well you proved them wrong
which is amazing it was funny yeah I
mean again when you work with great
people like Vince snow and and Rachel in
Island
yes magic happens but first she joins
Netflix's the Kaminski method for season
two and look they aged her up a bit
sitting in front of me no gray hair what
was that process like for you getting
ready every day on set I loved it it was
my idea when I met chart Lauren he
wanted me to be in the show he said I
looked too young and I said trust me all
I have to do is take all makeup off you
know bad lighting and a great wig I'm
there I'm lying I'm up there and be as
old as you want and and I went out and I
found that wig and I put the whole thing
together
you found the wig oh yeah yeah what I do
that all the time pretty much everything
you ever see me in I go and I get the
wig the costumes do the makeup and show
them because people are very
short-sighted they don't they look at me
and they go well can she play this and I
so I I create the character when I go to
meet them so you fight for these roles
then sometimes but I tried to make it
right
I mean he wanted me but he didn't know
you know he at the men don't know about
weights and makeup and suffer so you
just have to show them and get this
co-star Michael Douglas didn't recognize
her I've known him for over 40 years so
but I don't see him very often so it was
sort of like a an old reunion from back
in the day and the kids and house
Catherine and all that and then the next
day or two days later we're on set and
he introduces himself to me as Michael
recognize you with the gray didn't
recognize me of the gray so I was
absolutely thrilled
I went great yes I've got this character
this is it you know Madeline has arrived
so that was that was one of the nicest
things well watching you and Alan I mean
your guys's chemistry I feel like you
put him in his place a few times what
was that like for you it was really fun
um I watched season one and I loved it
but to actually go and work there with
him I mean there's there's a certain
rare parties there's a certain rhythm
that that things happen and he's just
magical to work with so it was really
fun I love my character too and she's
kind of sassy she is sassy and I just
think it's great to show an older person
who's sassy yeah yeah is she like you in
that way yeah yeah
I just I just color my gray hair I mean
your hair is phenomenal thank you I'm
getting to enjoy it while I can
yeah yeah but you know grace not so bad
Jane dates alan arkin x' character on
the show but in real life she's dating
david green dating older in life easier
or harder some things are harder but i
think for me i feel enormous freedom
yeah I took my life back about five six
years ago I decided I was gonna run my
own businesses I was gonna run my own
life I was gonna make all my own
decisions and if I found someone we'd
live together but do our own things and
do things together I've got lots of kids
and grandchildren and and he's got kids
and no grandchildren and and I and I
bought to experience everything that I
can with my kids so I'm taking my kids
traveling I took my daughter to Vietnam
and Indonesia and Bali two weeks ago I
took my twin sons to Monte Carlo
Florence and Venice and I want to show
them the world with me I don't want to
just you know have a figure you know
that when I'm dead and said oh you get
this you get that you fight over that no
I want to have experience you're living
with people that I love and with my kids
so when I can you mentioned you sort of
took your life back five or six years
ago
do you see marriage in your future I
don't see any reason for it at all
actually you know and and and if it's
about a commitment I think there would
be a private thing that I would do that
doesn't have to be legal I never want to
see a divorce again okay so what are you
doing you're married then you can
guarantee that right that's I mean you
married that secret yeah
[Music]